so dr jordan peterson got into twitter
beef with ethan klein either declines
from h3h3 productions he's a famous
youtuber um he's like now moved more i
don't listen to a ton of his content but
he's moved more into like more of a left
kind of space he does a podcast with
hassan [ __ ] the twitch streamer oh
gotcha he used to do uh like long-form
interview stuff and did an interview
with jordan peterson a while ago and
this is the tweet that he put out on the
14th years ago i interviewed jordan
peterson before i was very familiar with
his politics he was an interesting guest
who i enjoyed sitting with but
especially now i can see he's a
dangerous gateway to alt-right
transphobia and coveted misinfo i've
removed both interviews today yo that
gateway [ __ ] is is what is that
everything's a gateway like if i have
ice cream is that a gateway to diabetes
like for some people it is right and
then other people just eat ice cream and
it's regular yeah like those people were
probably gonna find the alt-rate
regardless i don't know if you can say
jordan peterson is the guy who did it
right i just think that that's super you
know what's funny is these same people
will laugh at uh marijuana being illegal
because everybody say it's a gateway
drug they would laugh at that idea what
is a gateway drug oh interesting and
they'll laugh and look down on those
people and then say oh he's a gateway to
alt-right
bro that's a way better example than one
eye yeah yeah i wish we just started
with
just say what he said yeah okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah ready
good right
amazing committers
i was trying to say one that ethan would
relate to more
you know so they had a back and forth on
twitter jordan peterson basically was
like hi ethan how are you we had a good
conversation i enjoyed meeting you and
talking to you what have i said
precisely that motivated your actions
and your accusation deleting our
discussion et cetera and then he's
basically like can i have the footage
basically considering that i went on
your show under the supposition that
there would be a conversation that would
be public yeah well he said the word
supposition he won dawg
so anyway he basically ethan klein
starts pointing it out he says you said
a ban on conversion therapy was moral
grandstanding uh he said that
he said that uh
wait what
yo you say you know conversion therapy
where a guy is gay and you're like no i
got therapy we're gonna make it oh now
we can't convert
now we can't convert now we
what if you want to convert to gay
should that be legal exactly what if you
want to be trans straight trans trans
straight conversion therapy should be
yeah yeah that's all i'm saying is all
of a sudden you can't do these things
what if you're dying on a beach in
hawaii you just want to get one kiss to
save your life what are you going to do
how do you do that yeah you want to get
one cocktail well you want to get one in
what do you do i just want to get one
kiss
he didn't do cpr bro i saved myself
i kicked a reese you were talking about
it
that's true love's kisses
he said jordan peterson you believe that
you believe in enforced monogamy that
you put in a new york times interview
and he put like links to all the times
that he said these things enforced
monogamy ain't that marriage
the [ __ ] is that uh jordan peterson
he was enforcing the monogamy that
sounds a little wild so far ethan's
making some sense i gotta say right he
said and then he also conversion therapy
is moral grandstanding he's a ban on
conversion therapy saying hey man you
can't just [ __ ] try to make these gay
kids straight that's illegal he's like
nah you're morally grandstanding that's
why i'm talking
yo george peter's a wild boy what else
was he talking about when i talked to
him he wasn't talking about none of this
[ __ ] yeah we were just talking about
michael sarah being a little [ __ ]
hey that's the guy that canceled the
flagrant university at the end of the
day we had to stop the whole series now
jordan misinformation peter's going to
probably say oh that's a uh
decontextualized version of what i meant
to say and he's just pulling words that
are sounding okay
that's your supposition yes i'm
supposing over here uh he said you
mischaracterized bill c-16 resulting in
a surge of transphobia your the bill was
created to add trans people to a
protected group against hate crimes
using the wrong pronouns would not get
anyone sent to jail uh in fact to this
day zero people have gone to jail unlike
what you've proposed um you've been
coming with receipts
screenshots to everything
as a person i found you amicable and our
conversation was very insightful but i'm
just not comfortable being a part of the
pipeline leading to takes like this
so and then hassan [ __ ] reached out and
was like hey jordan maybe if you want to
clarify some of your positions come on
our podcast
oh now we can get more views on them
that's foul
this hassan [ __ ] well that's a
different one though
they have a pod they have a show
together
wait a minute so he's willing to do a
podcast with them together but not the
one that they did well i think now that
he's more familiar with his his politics
he wants to challenge him on some of the
things that he's uh he felt he didn't
properly challenge them on the first one
yeah so let's run it back that [ __ ] is
corny
that's a play for publicity yeah you
can't do that show you just did it over
twitter i mean you just did that [ __ ]
you didn't know how to challenge those
points when he was like yo that
conversion yeah [ __ ] is for the birds
we gotta do it in public on a podcast
that [ __ ] is
phony well i think he's saying it
happened later so he said which is fine
just don't grant don't say like hey
you're banned you should not be allowed
on my platform allow them on your
platform and keep them on your platform
don't delete the episodes and then have
them on and say hey we disagree
you know that [ __ ] i disagree
with now maybe it's banned from the
internet maybe it's the comic in me but
like when somebody says some crazy [ __ ]
like that i want to hear them
rationalize it boy it doesn't matter
yeah yeah dr omar goes like white people
are evil i'm like tell me go for it give
me it dr lamar johnson is my favorite
bro like every single time he's on the
doctor
that's literally that's the only doctor
i trust yeah dr umar johnson yeah
100 percent right and dr martin luther
king
a doctor yes he was
well yeah it was we're talking about
doctor's real doctor he was a
chiropractor bro he's [ __ ] what he's
talking about
dr wilmore's a real doctor he's doctor
of pan-africanism
you know remove all the black people
from america and take them to africa
wait that's what he believes yes oh [ __ ]
i don't know to be honest with you i
just tried to make them talk to africans
about this they might feel away
i think you need to get their permission
carve out a little bit of land in africa
we think we've ever done that
that's what this is
[ __ ] out of here you can tell me i'm not
welcome back
whoa
so all i had to say should you take down
episodes or like content that you put
out in the past that you don't
necessarily it's your show you could do
whatever the [ __ ] you i agree exactly
what the [ __ ] you want i'm fine with
that i think that to be honest like i
think he brought up interesting points
i'm curious to see what jordan said
about that just because i like jordan so
i'm probably giving him the benefit of
his doubt but
objectively i got to say like yo if he
doesn't like these things that's his
platform he decides what goes on his
platform and he decides how much
responsibility he has for his listeners
you know what i mean like i personally
don't think that we have to be
responsible every single the person that
listens to the podcast i believe people
can make their own decisions and should
make their own decisions but if he feels
like his people are willing to do
whatever the [ __ ] they hear on the
podcast and that the other things that
he says and his beliefs don't have more
influence than a guy like jordan
peterson then okay do your thing i'm
actually not mad at that i'm not mad at
taking down i think it's corny to invite
him back and like hey come on another
episode and then we'll get mad now i'm
ready for you yeah yeah
and have him back it was a different guy
but they share a problem
but yeah the co-host i think would be
like no yeah but yo but here's the thing
i'm i'm
i would like to hear that convo because
now they're going to have the discussion
about those talking points and you're
probably going to hear jordan speak on
them in a better more coherent way yeah
and it might convince
i think no i think that's great i just
think don't ban the old episodes and say
oh you're dangerous and then bring you
back do both or do none no i feel like
bandit and then like what if they have a
convo is amazing they're like oh i
actually understand your perspective now
i want to put those episodes back up and
then it makes sense that'd be cool yeah
that'd be cool i think i really love
that combo i think that that'd be really
cool because he knows specifically what
he doesn't like about jordan peterson's
philosophy and then he gets to hear him
out and have him defend it and that's
rare yeah i actually really liked it i
hope they had that combo jordan seems
like just such a smart
dude who's so good at debate this guy
seems like he might be able to match
wits on the opposite side which would be
cool because normally a lot of debate is
just who's better at arguing if they're
both good at arguing i would love to
hear them go at this [ __ ]
yeah
i think we i think we've figured it all
out pay-per-view
yeah pay-per-view sign it up but the
problem thriller fight club
ethan klein vs jordan peterson